politique et société pierre bernard le
maire de montfermeil comparaissait
aujourd'hui devant la 17e chambre
correctionnelle du tribunal de paris à
l'origine de la faire une plainte du
mrap destinée à rappeler que depuis
trois ans au moins le maire de
montfermeil refuser l'inscription de
certains enfants immigrés dans les
écoles de sa commune
le point avec michel reinette et claude
du sud depuis trois ans un certain émoi
prévaut dans la commune de montfermeil
qui il est vrai accueille sur son
territoire
de nombreux étrangers 27 à 28% selon le
maire par des mesures radicales
il refuse l'inscription des enfants
étrangers dans les établissements
scolaires une façon dit monsieur bernard
qui comparaissaient devant le tribunal
de paris cet après-midi de susciter au
plan local les axes de réflexion au
débat national
il est temps il est urgent maintenant
que les pouvoirs publics mènent une
réflexion solide sur le problème de
l'immigration à montfermeil comme dans
d'autres villes qui n'ont pas en raison
du taux très important d'immigrés au
sein de leur population
les possibilités d'accueillir ces
émigrés comme on doit accueillir les
étrangers
et qu'en est il pour les enfants je vous
pose la question c'est quelque chose de
dramatique
c'est pour ces enfants essentiellement
que je me bats la logique du maire de
montfermeil est effarante
elle consiste à dire pour mieux
accueillir les enfants d'immigrés
chassons les élimine au lait ne les
scolarisant pas ceci est d'autant plus
grave que le maire doit de par la loi
veillez au respect de l'obligation
scolaire j'espère que le tribunal
prendra une décision qui signifiera
clairement que l'on ne peut pas prendre
des enfants en otage pour mener la
bataille politique contre l'immigration
que cette forme de racisme
est totalement insupportable envoyé en
délibéré le 25 février prochain cette
affaire pourrait servir de point d'appui
à l'action des exclus et des
organisations humanitaires qui les
soutiennent